thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video find out more later on hey 42 here
if you're constantly late for work
routinely miss deadlines find yourself
frantically shopping for presents every
christmas eve or shake your head in
disbelief as you submit your income tax
return late
again
then don't worry you're not alone and
you probably aren't just incompetent or
lazy either unless you're watching this
video at three o'clock in the afternoon
in your pajamas in which case all bets
are off
no what's far more likely is that you're
just a victim of what's called planning
fallacy a common human tendency to
overestimate how quickly we work or
underestimate how long it takes to get
things done
there's a third chance you see this play
out in your own life all the time but
even if you don't the planning fallacy
is an action all around you
sydney opera house took 10 years longer
to build than planned and cost 14 times
more than was budgeted for
[Music]
berlin airport took 15 years of planning
and even then the project finished nine
years late
and pinky and the brain plan to take
over the world every single night but
they're yet to succeed
so don't beat yourself up too much the
planning fallacy catches out people
whose actual job it is to plan stuff as
well as some other super smart
characters
in 1857
the philological society of london a
gang of word nerds dedicated to the
study of language declared the english
dictionaries of the day to be
on the whole a bit [ __ ]
and so they decided to completely review
and update every single word that had
been added starting from around the year
11 50 a.d
it was a massive project that would
eventually deliver the first edition of
what we know today as the oxford english
dictionary and by the time it was
published as one complete work it was a
10 volume monster that as far as anyone
knew contained every single word in the
entire english language
of course the society had known it was
an ambitious undertaking but
unfortunately they wildly underestimated
just how ambitious
instead of the expected ten years
it took seven decades before the full
dictionary was eventually produced in
1928.
in other words it was a master class in
planning fallacy
[Music]
now if you love traveling like i do then
you'll love the fastest and easiest vpn
surf shark did you know surf shark helps
to avoid price discrimination based on
your location so you can save money on
plane tickets and car rentals whilst
travelling
surf shark runs on any device anywhere
and it's packed full of features such as
industry leading uncrackable encryption
ip and dns leak protection an internet
kill switch of your vpn drops out and 24
7 customer support personally i use
surfshark to watch netflix content from
other countries such as the us that's
usually blocked here in the uk it's
really easy all you have to do is switch
over your location setting and there you
have it instant access to your favorite
programs surfshark maintains a strict no
logs policy so their network of 3200
servers in over 65 countries runs 100 on
ramp so they couldn't log your data even
if they wanted to by using the code 42
you will benefit from an 83 discount
plus three extra months for free all you
have to do is click the special link in
the description below
don't miss out
the project began at a snail's pace and
for the first 20 years or so not much
happened
but in 1879 the oxford university press
recruited james murray as editor
as well as being a philologist
language geek murray was also a
lexicographer
dictionary maker and it was under his
command that the oxford english
dictionary really took off
okay perhaps took off isn't quite the
right phrase
after a full five years of hard graft
murray's team made us as far as the word
ant
they worked from the scriptorium
especially constructed room that sounds
like it belongs in hogwarts where they
process to two tons of source material
collected by the theological society
unlike most dictionaries the oxford
english didn't just provide a definition
for each word it also showed each word's
history and quotes from various books
and articles were included to
demonstrate how each word may be used in
various eras
[Music]
before murray's changes this work was
mainly done by scholars and so the
quotes were overwhelmingly taken from
classical literature but unlike my high
school english teacher murray realized
that most people don't go around talking
like shakespeare and so he wanted the
english dictionary to reflect the
everyday language used by ordinary
people
the problem was to achieve that goal he
would need a metaphorical army to read
all of the english books and published
material
in existence in search of suitable
quotes for every single word in the
dictionary
so when it became clear to him that
progress was too slow or should i say
ponderous
or leaden-footed or sluggardly
murray launched possibly the first
crowdsourcing campaign in history
calling on english speakers and readers
in the uk america and british colonies
to send in english language quotations
from history books novels cookbooks
newspapers travel books and anything
else they could get their hands on
his plea to the english-speaking world
was well received and reinforcements for
murray's army of would-be wordsmiths
included about 500 american contributors
and around 800 brits these people were
by and large amateurs with nothing
driving them but a deep love of
cardigans and the english language
together this global force of bookworms
contributed more than one million
quotations
but there was one volunteer amongst them
who stood head and shoulders above the
rest
his name was william chester minor
and he was responsible for over 10 000
separate entries in the dictionary
second in volume only to murray himself
miner was an american doctor living in
the united kingdom but as murray would
eventually discover to his immense shock
there was far more to dr miner than just
a medical degree
you see the oxford english dictionary's
most prolific volunteer also happened to
be a convicted killer
and paranoid schizophreniac he worked on
his many thousands of contributions to
the world's greatest english dictionary
whilst serving out a life sentence at
broadmoor a psychiatric facility in
berkshire england
william minor was the son of american
missionaries and was born in present-day
sri lanka in 1834
he was sent to america to study at a
military academy at the age of 14 and
went on to graduate from yale university
as a doctor in 1863 right in the middle
of the american civil war
miner joined the union army as a field
surgeon and at the battle of the
wilderness in 1864 he was confronted by
the true horrors of war
this particular battle was notable for
its incredibly high number of casualties
around 29 000
and especially gruesome injuries
as well as all the usual wounds of
battle hundreds of soldiers were burnt
alive as the wooded area in which the
battle was being fought
caught fire over and above the trauma
that miner faced as a medic it said he
was also instructed to brand the letter
d onto the cheek of an irish deserter
for minor a man described as a
thoughtful and somewhat delicate soul
this event made a huge impression and
had a lasting impact not just on the
poor irishman's cheek but her miner's
mental health
later in life he would suffer from
paranoid delusions many of which
included being persecuted by an irishman
over the following years miner's mental
health deteriorated and he suffered from
an increasing number of schizophrenic
episodes
in 1868 he was committed to an insane
asylum in washington called saint
elizabeth's hospital and for obvious
reasons was released from service in the
army
in 1871 he traveled to london for a
change of scenery although it's hard to
see the therapeutic benefit of this
decision the world's largest city at the
time 19th century london was described
by many adjectives but relaxed and
tranquil
were not often amongst them
london was also home to a huge irish
population
many of whom were refugees from the
great famine
for a man who believed he was being
hunted by an irishman
it must have felt like a bit of a
nightmare
independent and living without
psychiatric care
minor was plagued by an increasing
number of paranoid episodes
and it was during one of these that
things took a dreadful turn
on the 17th of february 1872 minor
believed that a man had broken into his
room
and at about 1 45 a.m he ran out into
the street with a revolver
hell-bent on catching this imaginary
intruder he gave chase to an innocent
man named george merritt a stoker he was
on his way to work at a local brewery
before gutting him down with two shots
to the net
the lambeth tragedy as it will come to
be known generated international
interest and was widely reported
along with miners trial for murder
the court case revealed extreme problems
with mental health and minor was found
not guilty of murder by reason of
insanity
still he couldn't safely be released
into the general population and so was
sent to be imprisoned at broadmoor a new
asylum for the criminally insane
initially he was destined for bethlehem
hospital in london but he was turned
away due to overcrowding
if you've watched my recent video on
bedlam you'll know how lucky a break
that was
at broadmoor prisoners with some spare
cash could have their living conditions
substantially improved so thanks to his
family's money and military pension
miners digs were quite comfortable and
spacious
he had a two-room cell and it's even
been claimed he employed a fellow inmate
as a servant
on top of that he was allowed to indulge
in some of his hobbies including
painting and that all-time classic
prison pastime
playing the flute
but the passion that miner entertained
the most
was reading
he constantly bought new books and his
collection grew so large that he
converted his second room into a
dedicated library he was especially fond
of vintage and travel books
and when he came across one of james
murray's pamphlets recruiting volunteers
to help create the oxford english
dictionary it was these books that gave
him the most inspiration
whether minor was driven by the desire
to give something back to society
or to keep his paranoid delusions at bay
we'll never know
but once he started collecting
quotations in 1880 it seemed he couldn't
stop not even to play the flute
the american dedicated the next two
decades of his life to this work
contributing so much language that
murray once said the oxford english
dictionary could easily have covered the
last four centuries of words
just from miners quotations alone
minor was something of a mystery to
murray and the oxford dictionary team
for a number of years he signed off his
letters with only his name and location
broadmoor krauforn
berkshire
that's not exactly a lot of detail and
the group of lexicographers i don't know
how many more times i can say that word
believed minor was possibly a medical
man working at the asylum who happened
to have a lot of spare time on his hands
a number of accounts say that murray met
the mysterious minor at broadmoor in
1897 discovering to his tremendous
surprise that the doctor was not in fact
a staff member but a patient
whilst these stories make for a good
drama they turn out to be nonsense
balderdash cod swallow
bollocks
sorry i spent a lot of time reading the
oxford english dictionary whilst
researching this video according to a
letter written by murray the academic
apparently became aware of minor's
history some years before the pair first
met in 1891.
an american visitor had thanked murray
for his goodwill towards the poor doctor
minor revealing the tragic backstory
that had led to the army doctor's
imprisonment in broadmoor
murray and minor shared letters for some
time but murray was always careful to
keep what he knew of miner's situation
to himself when the men did eventually
meet it was the start of a genuine
friendship that lasted many years and
included murray making numerous visits
to broadmoor
some have speculated that william
miner's work on the dictionary was
useful therapy for him
but by 1902 his grip on reality was all
but gone
he believed that every night he was
abducted and taken to various locations
where he was forced to do unspeakable
things
a delusion that eventually led to him
cutting off his own penis
murray as well as other family and
friends campaigned to have minor
repatriated and finally in 1910 he was
released from broadmoor and sent back to
america where he spent the remaining
years of his life at saint elizabeth's
hospital
william miner was a tortured soul
but a keenly intelligent man who made an
extraordinary contribution to the
english language
next time you don't understand the word
it may be thanks to one of his 10 000
contributions to the oxford english
dictionary that you end up a little
wiser in linguistic terms he's an unsung
hero and for that he deserves our
gratitude
or appreciation
or regard
thanks for watching